[Music]
b-but I'm talking about hackers spots
and fake news bloggers and Internet
activist Marquess Beck at all and
whether it's possible that the German
election could be decided by the GMAT
Bhutanese mr. Beck at all
welcome to the DW interview you could
join us the ladies and gentlemen my name
is Thomas Bach mr. Beckett all there was
massive manipulation of the elections in
the US and France possibly originating
in Russia and the German government says
the German election is safe and we can
rest assured nothing will happen is that
fake news fake news well at least the
assurance to the public that they seem
to have everything under control
is a bit surprising especially since all
last year of quite a lot of panic was
created fabricated and rather the
opposite was communicated to the public
the danger from Russian hackers is
played down now it doesn't mean all our
infrastructure has become totally safe
that's a long process I think the only
thing that's totally safe after the
massive attempts we've see is the
assumption that they'll very probably
try again that's what everyone says and
history also shows that there have
always been foreign interests that have
tried to influence other states other
governments and other countries
elections so far in this election
process I haven't seen any attempts at
influence on the scale that was
predicted with such scare tactics for a
whole year
McCann's fear panic McAfee exact water
German Bundestag has already experienced
a massive hacker attack and it took
German democracy offline for days but we
learned from that manually untasted OT
Bundestag right we learned that the
German Bundestag had a very bad IT
security strategy that they'd made very
little
effort to guarantee the greatest
possible security that many
representatives had failed to improve
their security for the sake of
convenience predicted harm it turned out
the attackers or at least a group of
attackers took advantage of that and
deck warden now as he's indicated that
it might have been Russian hackers the
apt 28 group these indications were
drawn from analyzing the source codes
for the programming codes of the Trojan
software was found on Russian working
hours or Russian workdays and of the
occasional Cyrillic letter a target I'd
known haven't tsukuru Lucius I he didn't
do it
that's fairly weak evidence yes that's a
problem attribution or unmistakably
clear traceability if let's say I were
an American hacker spy and I wanted to
hack my friends in Germany I would make
every effort to make it look like it
wasn't friends but somebody else yeah
any man who really wants to can
influence things like for example
manipulate the vote count on Election
Day September the 24th well the Federal
Election Commissioner says the
infrastructure is secure we can't be
certain the infrastructure at the
municipal level might not be quite as
secure as at the federal level but at
least we can say we're lucky Germany
doesn't have computer voting you
couldn't summon Assange you're
completely silent I'd learn if we had
this so-called Evo tting online voting
if we voted over the computer like in
other countries we would be more likely
to see manipulation happening than with
paper-based voting because that's tried
and tested it can be monitored it's not
so easy to manipulate and by sticking
with this will hopefully be better off
in future
to come hopefully better good then
interconnected computers with certain
tasks or what they call BOTS decisively
influence in elections outcome where's
the danger not that great with warnings
about that quite often over the last
year warnings that automated propaganda
spread by BOTS could massively influence
public opinion going into the national
election and we've already said there's
been little indication of that it was a
kind of a mass hysteria here and now two
weeks before Election Day I can tell you
that the armies of bots we were promised
seem to be more active in other
countries India China nananana na keep
Savannah let's say the day of the
national election the news item starts
circulating on the internet about an
internal calculation by the Finance
Ministry that the costs for refugees are
not thirty five billion euros annually
but seventy billion wouldn't that
benefit the far-right I skip I can get
more meant for us even higher at the
moment false reports like that are
coming out almost daily and they're very
popular and get shared above all on the
right-wing networks but I don't believe
a document like that could have any
massive influence on Election Day
because most voters will have already
made their decision before they go to
the polling station and pack for Haggard
coffee still it's a major challenge but
also a great opportunity for reporters
to research these topics use their
contacts and the government to verify
the credibility of these reports we can
always find out that way if they're
genuine or not I think the German
newsrooms analyzed what they called the
macro leaks in the French election very
carefully and prepare themselves to deal
with such things in the German election
and I have utmost confidence in that
talk about a danger that hasn't gotten a
lot of attention yet Facebook now has
some 30 million members in Germany they
get newsfeed sorted by logarithms and
algorithms so that we don't understand
in German protector I need apartment via
the first time we're facing a danger we
as a society are becoming increasingly
dependent on monopolistic structures
like Facebook another question would be
does Facebook now have the power to
manipulate elections using all the data
it collects everywhere from its users
for example by giving people in hotly
contested electoral districts more
negative news about the Social Democrats
sharing more transparently positive news
about the Christian Democrats that's an
enormous challenge variety democracy
undertake beyond what so far nobody can
keep track of this in men kind of like
now nobody can keep track of it so it's
good that we're debating how we can
achieve accountability democratic checks
and what institutions we need to do that
I don't think we should just accept the
idea that Facebook has this power over
our society may use it in the future and
we can't do anything about it
personally some time ago you became the
subject of an investigation into
allegations of possible treason because
you had published highly confidential
intelligence service papers but the
matter was dropped and you were cleared
of suspicion how could anything better
have happened to spread the word about
you and your work and of course it was a
kind of badge of honor that the
government and our security agencies got
out the big guns they were threatening
us with two years in prison the
situation was just so surreal to us
we'd only ever heard of that happening
with repressive regimes think it was
possible in Germany to be threatened
with imprisonment for our workers
journalists with investigative reporting
techniques mid-calf fingers but we
hadn't and I had half a mind to drop the
whole matter because of the massive
pressure try explaining to your mother
who's just heard on the news that her
son might be facing prison that she can
rest easy now she couldn't sleep for a
long time this quantity langa technique
yes sir now I had the feeling that the
stigma remains of having been suspected
of treason and been investigated of
course that doesn't go down well
everywhere people think if you've been
investigated there must have been
something to it because they don't do
that for nothing
[Music]
your stigma
you're on the internet almost daily
you're at home there and have a
footprint but virtually nothing of your
private life can be found how do you do
that in Dimas there by going online very
consciously
I've learned how to cover up my data
traps which can often take some effort
and of course you have to give up a
certain quality of life that others take
for granted I'd like to talk about lots
of hobbies and interests of mine with
other people who might share exactly the
same ones and for that you have to open
up but as a public person I've decided
for me personally to advertise as little
as possible about myself as a private
person to me very well and I felt quite
satisfied with it to emerge to unfired
I'm a tiny
guns good and through me all kinds of
feelings your mother's still afraid you
might end up in prison I don't think she
is now I think after about two weeks she
was able to sleep through the night
again and then the case was closed
I became best Rebecca doll the wind up
her interview I'd like to give you three
unfinished sentences and ask you to
complete them without the internet
because I would be owner Internet via
this my life would have gone very
differently I'm very glad the internet
ain't of my life when it did the fact
the German mobile internet service is
worse than in Romania and Kazakhstan I
think is I think is an admission of
failure if you travel 5 kilometers in
almost any direction outside of Berlin
you're stuck in a dead spot for all the
industrialized members of the European
Union it's an admission of failure makes
you wonder who is responsible and who's
been governing us the past few years the
Internet age protecting democracy means
that's all dad our basic rights online
and offline have to be defended over and
over and ideally they should be expanded
like many things
thank you